[Music]
everybody going in wake up early in the
morning press play and let's get it in
cause we rocking with the fighter
[Music]
pandora cookies for chin's birthday chin
you tried hunting
you're at that age right i didn't try to
hide it yeah yeah you did oh yeah you
did it
you did it none of you guys remember
last weekend you said camping you say
anything about your 44 birthday you
should know i'm going camping for my
birthday dude
you always go camping you always go
camping i had an rv this time though oh
[ __ ] no harvey
bro i saw the pictures you showed your
girls out no it's all of our friends
like
see that's how i remember this morning i
was thinking about something i thought
about rvs and i was like why did chin
bring an
rv with a bunch of people and then i
thought about the month i was like wait
his birthday's in
april because i think i'm the only one
who has like all the birthdays written
yeah
i think so and then i checked my phone i
was like oh [ __ ] your birthday was on
saturday
and then i texted you like hey i'm so
sorry this morning she was very sweet
she texted me happy birthday meanwhile
he has mentioned it on the show no yeah
yeah yes
did you guys even follow my instagram
the last post i did was a giveaway
on my birthday
i'm on the ground like that man no i
didn't really announce it was more like
a giveaway giveaway for subscribers to
youtube so i said i'm going to give it
away on my birthday
give away what a drone oh dope and i
still haven't done it
did you say that yeah yeah yeah he did
say that
but you didn't tell me i don't
who knows who knows i don't know bert i
don't know anybody's birthday in here
what
what you wait i know i don't nobody's
birthday we just had three on this
planet
that it's my job to remember birthdays
and i tell brenda i i mean
that's like one of my main ones my mom's
around late march
i think my dad's is november 13th jay's
the seventh year
may 5th yeah i don't remember are you
well that's grown man this every day
december 23rd like at that time oh wait
i got you july
5th nope third yes this i always do that
that's right july 3rd yeah birthdays are
tough i always do fifth huh
yeah you always do the first time you're
at that age where you're getting older
so you try to kind of just it's not a
big deal i
i don't purposely hide it but i never i
purposely don't tell people
dog you do not look 47 years old i'm not
47.
we don't know anything about you i just
turned 44
and also korean birthdays are different
they you it's like
korea like you're already a year old
when you're when you're born or
something like that oh really
i'm either i might be i'm either younger
or older i don't know so
wait when you come when you come out the
womb you're a year old one yeah and i
was born in
korea really yeah that's interesting
that's [ __ ] stupid
you might as well that's stupid because
i've always thought about that why don't
we do that
because you're not 365 days old you're
one day old
that's why we don't do it it's called
science so as soon as you got the one
where you go to school
come on that don't make any sense i
think it's just because those countries
value life so much that they consider
like the time you're in the womb
as you being alive that's just how we
see like being in the wombs alive
yeah in the world but that's just like
in that culture
what we consider to be like your life
you're still not in the womb for a year
though
yeah it's just easier to round up to a
year then that's what christian looks
like nine months
i got on my camera last week but once we
have the new studio
everyone could be campered up that
korean culture is insane so so is you
born you're one years old yeah yeah i
don't understand
you said other asian yeah so uh
vietnamese people do it too
so he's korean so i would be 26. but
really you're 20. you know what you
really
you told us this before so over in
vietnam when i see my relatives and they
ask how old i am i tell them 26 rather
than 25. it's insane
it's crazy that makes no sense i like it
you guys do a lot of things right but
you guys are off on that
yeah i got i moved with brendan so i'm
35 yeah
in korean korean korea korean 35. how do
i say thank you in korea
but also i don't know where my birth
certificate is so my parents kind of
be older you look like i could be older
and younger you look younger children oh
so you
did too when he came to this country he
didn't have his uh like a birth
certificate so he wanted
to go back to high school when he was
here in america to receive an education
so he lied about his age yeah so he had
like two real birthdays
who was this uh my dad all your dad yeah
so he has like an american birthday
which is
a different date from dominicans do that
that's why they're like [ __ ] they say
oh i'm 18 there's 37 playing baseball oh
yeah
like yo romero's like oh i'm only 43 and
everyone thinks he's like 62.
oh what did you see
and where'd you guys go chin same place
lake achuma it was a bunch of us so
there's
two other rvs i think so i drove one and
then uh two other people just
do drugs and [ __ ] hug each other
again
some people definitely did some stuff
but i didn't this time just didn't feel
it was just yeah
it's your birthday i mean i drank like
crazy i cuddle with my girlfriend
okay oh there you go and then i want my
friends to you know oh
we're tight i hug my friends all the
time
really yeah i'm a big hugger really i
know not with you
i don't know even with jay i'm like i
hug jayla doesn't like hugs
jay doesn't like being touched she
always allows me to hug him really yeah
strange
yeah i think i've ever hugged them
he was getting it this is impressive man
are you playing
two reps when you're gonna do one yeah
good oh man jeremiah will you teach me
to do 115
and you've never touched 315 right never
only read about it
i've read about it i've never been
expressed before until uh
that's insane look how slow you're going
to that's competition style dude bro all
the way down as well
yeah and you got it i bet we get three
to four you get a little faster
chappelle you would be so good at
powerlifting you have like the ideal
body frame for power lifting yeah really
yeah you have good range of motion every
power lifter
in zoo culture any power lift i've ever
seen they're so out of shape
i get it i get it you're stronger
he goes come on man that's easy way he
didn't know that i did like a drop set
so i was like i you know was basically
going heavy to like
like burning up but i was like yeah i
was like you know
on the lightest weight and that but like
my own you're also with me and mark
harley so i
look at him like he literally he's like
40
he goes man that is easy wait you got
this it's all in your head and i'm like
dog it's a drop set he goes
oh okay he goes i didn't know
so straight up powerless
like a lazy man's workout i'd say power
lifters are more
they concentrate more on like being able
to lift a certain amount
they want to be rather than how you yeah
but they don't do cardio right
uh some of them do but not really they
won't be as heavy as possible because
the more you weigh the more weight your
meal put up yeah correct
okay maybe maybe doing work yeah in the
strong man competition yeah
above handles and [ __ ] yeah after a
while though get powerlifting gets
boring
did you yeah i used to powerlift and
then i got to a point where i was like i
can't i don't want to lift anymore
but one of my boys he's a power lifter
he doesn't look bad not all power
lifters look back no no
most of them do a lot of emotions
they're just they they look like they're
like sloppy joes i got a homie named
jesse
in great shape what kind of power lift
are we talking hold on go to my profile
your profile yeah like those olympic
powerlifters
go to my friends go to my friends your
followers
your followers or who i'm following who
i'm following who i'm following
and typing beasts oh we can't really
type in here
first of all you follow way too many
people hey because i know a lot of
people
yeah not two thousand you have a lot of
friends that's what you're looking come
on you gotta realize i lived in four
other different states
or yeah yeah i get all that two thousand
too many though
no that's not you do have more frenzy
but i know
he's british dude yeah he was the
strongest man in the world for a second
which he looked this one deadly he had
he had the deadlift in record yeah
that's what i think i've known for
the beast yeah center
you built like my manager lex bro they
eat they have like a jar of like
like fish they need calories dug any
calories they're hard lifters are the
ones that'll
stop doing a set eat in between like
yeah
and they drive
well they want the weight to push the
weight yeah you gotta be three something
to do something
yeah they're big boys man it's taking
too long fighting friend though you know
crashing
who is that but yeah anyways we
transition from a power lifter to a
bodybuilder
look how jacked it was as a power lifter
i know you know strongest man in the
world
colorado springs brian shaw brian shaw
shaw colorado
uh colorado boy he's like five guys he
has to be damned near 400 pounds because
he's like six
eight what's his name again brian shaw
he wrestled uh
dustin poirier as a joke that's a joke
yeah he's huge
dude [ __ ] he's the strongest man in the
world six eight that's that color out of
water dog
yeah dude he's got water look how big he
is
he lifted five tires jesus christ oh
yeah he's tall as [ __ ]
yeah he's super huge dude oh he looked
like the mountain from game of thrones
the mountain mountain doesn't he compete
with the mountain oh yeah
they compe they compete against each
other oh they do okay
oops damn bro look how much weight that
is on the side chin
when that bar the barbell is bent 990
pounds god
damn deadlift colorado's finest
whoo shout out to him bro six eight if i
had that genetics he's so big
oh how'd your commercial do go oh well
you [ __ ] up your
one line people [ __ ] up one line are you
the one telling me you're up all night
studying for it i did no no you said it
no you said i was only
all right
[Laughter]
we made the joke there we go i thought
that was real life
real life it was and then i don't know
what y'all said after the show we said
you were good at acting oh cause a lot
of fans was rating my movies
uh bernie there's like i'll watch bernie
sands give it a six i was like what the
[ __ ]
yeah so fans are saying they give this
movie well they get my performance at
six
yeah they give you a performance this
season good thank you bray doing me
dirty bro yeah
i got i was crying i cried on the spot
yeah i did my own stunts
you could tell which one i am but
it's not like about you you're so little
i feel like
if you just showed me the legs i
couldn't tell which one's melody i could
do malik
yeah legs yeah you had to go there's so
many other pictures i'm gonna go down
i did i did it for you dude oh damn
you're in the the poster
yeah that's yeah i have a potent part in
that movie
i played dwight the football player uh
the jock so
i don't know if anything but so how did
that actually he you flirt with the girl
at the
end all right all right i'll watch the
movie
yeah don't spoil it dog oh it was
meanwhile you spoil everything
already out there how long how long has
it been out uh 2016.
a hot second yeah exactly and it's still
on netflix
yeah it's still there yeah just did it
yo first netflix movie uh by the college
about a college yeah because not before
this no college movies oh is this a
netflix original
originally it's original okay out of
college without a car yeah you can
listen this is the first one i went to
sundance
netflix original yeah about a college
campus yes or black college who gives a
[ __ ]
hold on you're saying it was the first
netflix movie
on a college campus what kind of feat
is that hey man you know we were the
very first ones ever
to have a college in one shot
did you know that did you know that or
do you want to give me
right now is it uh hbcu or whatever yeah
hbc oh there you go
i think i just met regular college no no
regular college as well they say that
sundance
that'll make sense what a stupid credit
why would they say
that because that was big before in 2016
you cannot find a netflix original that
had like a high a teenage college movie
on there it was the first one and it was
a teenage college movie that would make
sense
it's a stat and i'm on it what a stupid
stat
who but who created teenagers 2000 when
did that come out 21
thank you bro we were the first ones
bruh i mean is that good
i mean who cares bro just know i'm in
the records of netflix
that's all i care about thank you i care
exactly
you type in first netflix original
college movie you'll see
brenda's mind
because they had like this uh all-white
film called goat or something like that
we had to compete with and uh that was
on netflix
so so how did that long story oh yeah
it went well shout out to the fans for
like helping me get online
uh because uh get my man tight so yeah i
don't want to spoil it it'll come out
when you see me yeah please don't spoil
it yeah um
yeah that was the first one we had to
compete with and that's like a
fraternity yes yeah
they put it side by side yep do they not
have an animal house on netflix
oh did i have american pie too that's
not netflix original stuff oh you're
saying
original yeah on netflix what a weird
thing that's one of the jonas brothers
mm-hmm yeah that's the one that's really
talented nick nick johnson
yeah they was hating on his guitar
playing on cmt
the cmt awards i didn't see it you told
me i hated it on his like guitar solo
they said it was like really bad
don't watch her enough what joe jonas
guitar have you seen it it's just
i mean right now i'm digging it
it was like first black cop that was
just that was for you and i
think that's the other guitar guys yeah
man i'm done with this show
the [ __ ] game too now to china
chappelle's
hey what's up with uh with sheila the
car
bring up the graphics let's see what
offers we've gotten for it i actually
got
a legitimate offer let me pull it up
right now okay okay legit no
no you have offers too in your dns yeah
let's hear his first okay i mean i'm not
gonna lie i looked at the
uh the comments for on the fly we posted
a lot of them were just offering maybe
food like cookies for
sheila or or even offering that you pay
them to take sheila off
one person offered uh they wrote me and
they offered
your mcdonald's meal that you ordered in
naples
all right let's see what we got here it
says does the car come with a bluetooth
speaker nah
it does this car is an ectomorph keeps
going
okay all right doggy i got a dm that was
30 i'll give you
3 400 cash right now was a dm i got i
got the same one
is it from elias hold on let's see i
told him to let you know
also got a guy who said he'll be he'll
buy it for 5 300
but he's in utah but i have to i have to
pay for shipping but that's
like 500 shipping that comment right
there associate to his own car
malik v sales associate what's his name
what's his name
elias yeah yeah yeah he's for real then
okay he dm me
he said if he sent it to two people then
yeah okay
the the utah guy or the cash guy the
cash guy this utah guy said i'll have to
pay for it uh for the shipping
that ain't nothing okay there's actually
i mean
it's all the way on the other coast but
there's this car service called cash for
clunkers they'll give you 3 400 for
3 500 for like right off the bat right
now yeah
to ship my car though that's the only
downside no we could ship it to uh
salt lake city i bet for 600 and then
you make you know
good amount of money my boy greg my car
expert guy can get it done but
once i release him you you would have to
get an m4
one once again on greg are you serious
about it i'm so serious like a lot of
fans
then i'd say we have my guy greg deal
with it because he'll get he'll get you
cash for it and then
get you into m4 yeah i want to i want to
be an m4
can you afford them for is the problem
yeah well let's let's talk man
you see all the stuff that he does by he
can afford this m4
right man you just got you you just
gotta cut back your call you know like
on what you're buying and [ __ ]
yeah so let's say you said like last
episode it was like six hundred dollars
a month right i didn't say six hundred
dollars you said seven hundred dollars a
month i didn't say something you
probably said like close to a g
damn did you say i didn't say anything i
i don't think he said no i said
uh you rounded it up no what i did is i
said you your pet your
your nuts can be about 53 grand
i'm assuming about 53 grand for m4
playing four
well what's the payments on 53 grand
chen i would assume
you buy it and then we want eleven hundo
cpo 100k um
uh warranty yeah i didn't think you gave
him
did you the monthly payment for
2016 m4 is with 34 000 miles
is 707 2016 is not going to be under
warranty
that's true i need 2018. it's going to
be a little more money
we don't know that yet all right i
thought the ones we were looking at were
all
16's like the ones that we were pulling
up no so there you go but
i'm thinking about twelve hundred
dollars a month for a car
for a fifty thousand dollar car yeah
that's why because it's expensive
but then if you put a lot of how much
down can you put oh i could put well
plus sheila if they pay for that
they might add more to you might have to
pay them more to take sheila too though
if you want to roll it into that no no
no no no no
i gotta do it but here's the thing so uh
50 to me was with you
so we really got a car around 54.55 you
put four
down really at 50 grand okay that's
worth four grand out because i don't um
didn't we look at m4s they're around
like 53 56. there's one guy
dm me he said he can find me a car in
houston and you'll drive it up don't
listen
okay cool i'll leave it
don't
i was hoping we get a clear-cut offer
from the fun and kids post but
yeah they were all just really ripping
on it more than anything
and rightfully so meet me at 2 40.
i mean i got a video of the bluetooth
that yeah listen
they you don't you're not advertising my
car go to chappelle story please
this guy said trade in for calf implants
i'm not gonna lie i thought about it i
saw that i saw that
that's hilarious i thought about it
go all the way look look at this go and
you have to put it on me
don't worry about that oh oh yeah you're
here your new haircut is dope man
thanks bro that's it give me the
anywhere last one
just come
and the video shuts off it's included
too
uh all right they said that all right
listen i get away from four
hours hey i was trying to help i was
like i'll really used to hell my boy
greg but you better be serious
because he don't [ __ ] around i'm serious
but that's 1200
a month no i mean
think about it if you cut off certain
things you can make it happen say less
you just gotta cut out something let's
cut back on shoes and yeah
and white tees for a little bit yeah i
know you got a lot of white teeth
yeah you got you got enough maybe maybe
maybe pass on the jewelry for a little
bit yeah yeah shout out to your cousin
yeah brother-in-law i mean because
you're chilling
he didn't know what i didn't know
uh yeah i think if you cut back on shoes
that's the biggest thing
but also maybe m4 maybe we're not at n4
level yet and that's okay
we're thinking we could look at them too
what's there oh yeah they did it
was cheaper too but that's cheaper but
the the m2 competition
might be around he doesn't need to
complain yeah i'm just saying
he's going from a center why are you
just getting five series
why don't you just get a five series
instead instead of an m2 or an m4 you
get like the top of the line regular
bad idea either what's the what's the
five seat i never like just that's more
your vibe
yeah because you're not you're like a
racer yeah you're not yeah i'm not a
race car guys that m5 right there
45. 2018 uh
m2 okay
m2 is gonna have nicer interiors a
little more spice in the engine only
twenty two thousand
you might not have that red interior you
want right we could find red
you can find it yeah we can find them
too okay
well also you you like bmws you're
stuck on a bmw listen it's bmw's i was
i was always a lexus guy but i mean i'm
talking to jay
ain't nothing wrong with that those
lights are cool now keep going
no keep going i didn't mean to do that
alex's are dope hey justin drives up
no those are sick
are just volkswagens if you think about
it volkswagen no hold on
hold on bugatti's owned by volkswagen
volkswagen and make the bugatti those
are still
made from there toyota makes the left oh
i didn't know that yes
it's it's it's toyota parts and alexa i
like how you backed us though
yeah you did thank you also and if you
don't like uh he said like if you're not
into that race car thing you can also
do the five series with the m package
like it has all like
the stitching in the seat like as the m
series steering wheel
everything like the black rims will come
with it and it's let me hit you on there
what about a new supra
toyota supra you're seeing one of those
you look flying one of those
that's a super let me it's the new supra
is that she knows what i'm talking about
soccer mom car oh
you ain't ready for 49 brand new bro
hold on brand new 50. that we're going
to
use one daddy i mean but they just came
out too they're about a year old
exactly yeah
that's not my style yeah this morning
listen we can't be rolling around with a
big scar
you write home let me just tell you
people oh i'm sorry
but you can do an essential but you
can't do in the supers
come on man you know we can't be we
can't be seen in no
[ __ ] super dog we can't be listening
to a baby in the soup bro
doc he's you guys been twerking around
that [ __ ] center like it's a bentley
man
you're right hey that is not so fair
but again are you talking about boston
but you said you like lexus
i do love we need a dope lexus the lf
one
the one that justin's got is though i
want a coupe though yeah they have coops
they have the rs the rc's the coupe
what's the one that justin got
he has the sedan that uh body okay
yeah i like that yeah that's nice that's
dope i can ride around in that
yeah we get one of those for about 35.
oh from your guy
uh yeah i'm sure okay really yeah i
think he sells like i'll buy that
tomorrow he said i think he sells like
says
yeah is it lexus high-end well no not 32
30. look at that look at that crispy 33.
even that yellow is hard i like that we
got this
but that's right there in inglewood i
can yeah i can get a lexus i'll get that
out black out the rims black out the
rims yup
how we doing also listen i don't i want
a card that
i don't want the wheel to shake when i
go over sixty thousand or sixty miles
per hour
so uh anything any new car you'll be
good man yeah okay yeah i'm gonna be
humble with it yeah yeah but i like you
don't want that
now you know how we would like to make
happen
we ain't m4 yet okay yeah yeah yeah yeah
you know what you weren't too much
we did it that was jake that's jake that
was just sj that's your brother they
don't know your financial situation
don't
and also we can tell i live above my
means we gotta all agree
but uh i'm starting to dial it back like
they said stop buying a lot of shoes
yeah
so i think lexus would be a good fit or
just a standard m3
yeah well let's go with the lexus first
and then if we don't have that we go to
the m alexis lasts
forever too yeah yeah yeah they're great
cars great
great their electronics suck what
bmws last long too oh yeah yeah forever
okay
the maintenance costs a lot more on
bimdo though why it's just a more
expensive car yeah
and my friends have them and they break
they break down fairly often yeah
no my dream car is not a bmw jay talked
me into that he was like what's your
dream car
oh my dream car oh being a benz
well one yeah yeah you got to be no
which one the 63 amg
okay that's fine um because we could you
could
you got some bad news hold their value
like [ __ ]
don't don't don't do 63 mg he ain't
getting that right now all right
i'm not jay i'm really window shop he
can't windows 2018
or 2019 37 daddy yeah but ben's just
have a lot of problems
they do no they don't i had one they had
a [ __ ] ton of problems what year was it
it was 2012 but even when it was when it
was
not that old it still had a [ __ ] ton of
problems don't listen to them man okay
i'm not they don't want to see you
flirting
with you i went from i want them in a
band
i love mercedes i transferred over to
bmw once i got mine i fell in love with
it
that's that's the c300 i don't want the
c300 which one you want 300
i want to see this this one's this
the c63 he wants three yeah you still
want the red interior we ain't there
right now we're not there yet but i just
wanted
the interiors of the mercedes but
maintenance on that is a [ __ ] too
what'd you say maintenance on that is a
[ __ ]
i mean they're not really especially
they're under warranty you don't do
mercedes yourself though
yeah i own a mercedes i have a jeweler
wagon
those are sick but
that's the family wagon huh so we
when the family go out you drive that g
wagon or do you take that uh
uh we do we take the g wagon you don't
you don't take the
it just depends but usually the g wagon
oh um all right
okay great do you have the amg g wagon
or the g63 it's called i think
those are i will admit those are better
than the bmw trucks i love those oh yeah
those are fire all right well listen i'm
josh i'm a graduate
i'm a graduate yeah you're going to
graduate yeah i think alex is a good
starter yes
i'm with you yeah i want the lexus coop
you don't like jeeps
no no i mean all right yeah that's your
thing doesn't it don't push your agenda
you leveled up yeah don't push that guy
i'm not even getting it
so those are basically just uh
lamborghini's doug but they are
because audi owns lamborghini the same
engine as lamborghini what about an audi
coupe
uh how these things are five or what is
it no no no
what's wrong with howdy nothing they're
great they're not some of the best
interiors
why are you tilting your head like that
because he's not ready for that look
we're talking about [ __ ] he ain't ready
for that one was forty thousand
which one that little eight three go
hold on hey it was 85. i had a corolla
they're pretty damn good he's a grown
man
yeah man i got queen and stuff right
yeah all right
look it's v 40 41 000. that a5 would be
dope i'm just trying to understand your
price range
for like this it's not 1200 a month uh
for a car
price range i mean i don't need that
that'd be yeah you don't need that nut
right now no
you're just getting started i'm just
getting started you don't want that life
man
let's get some so what's ideas you know
you're doing shows enables and [ __ ] to
cover the bills
yeah i think likes your best yeah and
i'll be reliable
yeah see there we go hey i i can put
yeah
don't let jay push his german car agenda
on you man
james our family only [ __ ] with germany
jay can sell
water to a fish like the way he sets it
up he's like she comes with cars and you
he's saying i think he's
you what jake is selling you i love jay
like he he sent me articles about nose
and [ __ ]
yeah yeah he's like bro trust me i see
the vision for you i see the fishing for
you james trying to get you in debt all
right is that what it was
had a hidden motive in there but not i
like the lexus i'm gonna get the lexus
33 000.
uh how much is that a month for what uh
now you're looking around 800. okay
that's perfect
how much was it again let's say 35 35
000.
we want a nice and i'm gonna put this
i'm gonna put like nine down that's
lease
he's gonna have to buy it's used yeah
i'm gonna buy oh buy yeah
oh you're gonna have to buy you have to
use
yeah put like nine down so i got 8 25
dog say less go get it all right that
works
yeah that works that's easy there you go
all right well i appreciate that all
right
well also sheila has to go so you can
hit up your guy
okay he can really take that car and get
rid of it
gotta go gotta get up out of here yeah
so now you now you're feeling it
you're letting her go i'm letting it go
i'm gonna drop this what i'm gonna do
i'm gonna just go
to like all the spots that i had fun
with chilling and just like yo
go memories memories and stuff like that
i had hallmark yeah exactly that's why
we drove over here today that's why we
drove here yeah i don't know how long
i don't know how much longer she got
left you know she should be written in
so
hell yeah and forget the fans they talk
about my lug nut was missing
it was yeah i'm gonna get it fixed yeah
i got bad news fellas stevie just texted
me he's not coming to houston
i mean he's not coming to austin or
houston
oh really i think he's mad we made fun
of alpacas
that'd be funny if that was the thing
that got him he goes you know what
[ __ ] him man i [ __ ] love those tails
and they didn't say [ __ ] the only thing
they said about the alpaca it looked
like justin teeth and i swear to god and
justin got his teeth fixed he just
got his teeth fixed he didn't send you a
pic he's not gonna send a pick he's not
gonna say no you're not gonna man we try
to get justice in the picture
they're completely better he got all of
it out of there i had him on my podcast
he got a lot of steve you guys said i'm
coming for all y'all yeah he did say
that he's coming for all of you guys
just don't bite us
[Applause]
he said i was gonna do it anyway i went
no you weren't did i not tell him that
to his face i said no you weren't
oh yeah yeah you didn't say it doesn't
know you weren't saying he just said
i was gonna do it anyway man you didn't
move me into this i wasn't gonna do it
anyway
that never happened that was the first
thing he did in my pocket and he goes
hey look at my teeth
okay this shit's crazy the camera
started rolling he just said look at my
teeth we had a whole plan set up
brendan he was like yo he was gonna get
on the podcast
and he was go it was gonna be like a
nice eat the beat like easter
and he was just gonna start he was just
gonna reach out freestyling getting
pretty
he's driving roasting me you know he's
just a light just enough for me
you don't want this fire jay he called
yesterday he was like
you know what i thought about it we
ain't gonna do it we're gonna save it
oh [ __ ] me and justin her friend
i'm doing him a [ __ ] solid dude look
at his teeth now
we gave him a two he's definitely a five
now you're gonna give him a two
three three that's right he's definitely
a six now bro i always did he was always
i'm just
no not with those teeth no no no no no
no no no no no no no no i don't want to
be refreshed
he don't post a lot no you don't post a
lot so maybe his stories he only posts
one around the road oh he got hit there
he's with his legs
nice look at that and you know he got
his teeth done
he's hiding it though forehead blowing
it
forehead going ain't it
get the kobe's on yeah i got a couple
yeah look look he always bite that
yeah yeah he's covering it up and
doesn't have to do that anymore
how dope is that
you know the fool's not even clowning
how dope is that oh you see it yeah
it is you see it i don't think they're
fixing i don't think they're fixed right
now they're not fixed but now he's he's
flourishing man
yeah yeah version yeah crushing the game
yeah he came he was like yeah
he got 11. probably when he started
rolling with us you know he only had
like 2
000 followers look at him now they am
now killing flourishing the teeth are
good
he called me he was like man i'm on your
ass yeah he said i'm coming for
all y'all because he understand he's
girl like you know his thing is like
y'all hang with the crew you know get
the women and stuff like that then when
you bag on about his teeth
and then girl's like well you know i
haven't you know oh
why is that like why is that worse than
y'all
yeah like chappelle like me and
chappelle had weight problems look at us
now dog
you saw him on 315. now did i do it now
did i do
335 for eight yeah i did he did
he did and you said we saw the text that
you sent b as well
but to say who said brian oh he posted
it he posted he was like what do you
post
he posted on our chat no on uh on
instagram we saw what he said no he did
yeah
watch what brandon said to me i
threatened him
what do you say
i kill you so easy right now kill bare
hands you
whenever i want i can hear it dude
and everyone's like basically saying
yeah he'll kill you but yeah
i always threaten brian you strong yeah
bro we saw you we saw you today with the
chains around your neck and the thick
boy world
yeah yeah yeah i took that phone nation
that new mark is dropping in may dog
yeah
i mean brian's posting combos now huh
better watch what i say
look at that oh yeah big boy nation
all right how many pull-ups you're doing
that with the chase 10 yeah
he gets like 10. i can't do that that
way on your hand
yeah the other hand the way you're doing
is harder yeah this should be i can only
do this
that's crazy yeah chabelle's strong like
this that's interesting
and then mark was like dude try this
because we're trying i was like yeah
struggling this this way yeah i think
right now i'm so strong because i took
so much time off from the gym
and then my body recovered and now i'm
the strongest i've ever been yeah really
hands down strongest i wonder what it is
for me let's take a break but you're
also new to it too
so now you're just building off a
foundation breaking down your muscles
right now so
it takes some time to recover because
i'm black
what hmm maybe sit this one out
like no so you break this you break down
your muscles and then you you know gives
your body some time to rest and stuff
like that and you come back even more
strong i've been in the weight room
since fourth grade oh yeah yeah i've
been waiting
when i was cheering i wasn't this size
no when i was cheering i was
a lot smaller i was just shredded easier
yeah but you put on muscle now that's
why i say don't weigh yourself
yeah yeah you're putting muscle muscle
is that what it is is it more than fat
for sure it's denser that's why
is that true yes yeah like per ounce
with that hair cutting that new body la
9.
give me that [ __ ] bro you changing
right now i looked at you the other day
i was like looking at your feels like
bro you almost handsome
you almost you right there with that
haircut yeah
the cuffs no i saw him this one like
damn dog yeah yeah
yeah exactly i was looking at it
i was like i could go out with him yeah
yeah
i went to my barber yesterday i said man
give me that dress
last time was cool and all that yeah
give me the drake yeah
i literally said that and that's what he
gave him i'm outside in the air
bro i feel like you're way better yeah
you do
you're different yeah yeah and you can
sing a lot of people didn't know that
i i don't think i can sing oh okay
people think i can sing
i i you know i'm just self-conscious
about it
you can't you can't kind of sing though
you can kind of you can hold a note
you can hold on no you can sing
alternate depends on the song you can
sing alternative
because i am barely breathing i'm just
kidding
he was already emotional what's that
song
records right breathing
yeah what the [ __ ] is that song duncan
chic oh yeah yeah
ducky sheep why do i know that song
that's a great
that's a crazy you know where that song
heard it i bet you've heard it yeah you
probably heard it
it's you heard it yep have you earned it
i don't know i think you would have to
play it for me i mean i would
you're pretty young dog compared to
everyone you and i when when were you
born what year
98 bucks came around 97 nice came out in
96.
oh yeah i know this i also grew up with
two older brothers so i was always
watching [ __ ] that was like around there
yeah he's still young
[Music]
who does it classic maybe you might know
about the chorus
yeah by the chorus yeah yeah
[Music]
we should cover this let's do it oh do
it you can do something
with your musical talent do something
dude let's do some jam sessions new
studio once it's built
okay we could do that yeah live jam
sessions you guys we have coffee
whiskey i can bring my hellcat
[Applause]
800 horsepower it's a tim armstrong uh
custom guitar
that's the difference between us what
hellcat to use a guitar hellcat to me is
a [ __ ] car
okay records or hellcat what dodge demon
or hell okay
oh no the the demons that big boy that's
not a thousand horsepower yeah but it's
the one up have you seen the uh hellcat
red eye
i haven't seen that you ain't ready you
know for the longest time i wanted a
dodge challenger
that was like i used to have one that
was the first like car i bought with my
youtube
charger
no the hellcat is the uh charger is it
no the hellcat's the challenger looking
one
yeah and the demon is the charger but
there's i think there's a hellcat
eye and it comes with like 1100
horsepower really
yeah they're not those dream car i don't
know why shelby gt5 dodge demon
those are cool those are dope no those
things are [ __ ] sick yeah i love
challenges yeah the hellcat red eye
daddy why'd you get rid of your
challenger just
uh because i grew up yeah yeah i had 22s
on it
it was all black black rims is when i
was making [ __ ]
pennies in the ufc it was cool at the
time okay
yeah i like i like yeah i used to love
those cars that's like yeah
yeah that's younger that one's not
but they're fun man man i got like post
trauma stress
wait what's the what's the demon the
dodge demon
is the charger charger version the
charger charging
they're cool though it's dope because
back in the day like the shelby gts and
the camaros and all that
the road runners these come like with
all this horsepower and they're like
american motor you know power yeah and
then they went away from it but dodge is
really the only one still doing it
everyone's going to electric or like the
uh ecoboost
yeah for the dodge challenger no for all
like
mustang uh corvette really doing stuff
like that oh what did we see
recently huh for the better environment
why do you yeah i don't i don't know
like that and there's
like the one thing that's not like
straying away from power being their
main thing what did we see in naples oh
a mustang tesla
oh the truck no it wasn't a truck it was
something like
it was an suv yeah it was them they
caught the new mustangs the all-electric
mustangs
yeah i don't know why they called it
mustangs that should be but i know yeah
totally an suv
yeah they're i don't know why you guys
were so excited to see that piece
i never know i wasn't excited i was just
like i didn't know that existed look
like a tesla yeah
yeah that's like an electric car
oh that was a corner why were they they
were all hype about it why would they
disrespect mustang like that though
i don't know because it looks like a
mustang yeah but it's
it didn't look bad though yeah it's a
cool car i don't
get one of those malik no i'm not keep
that same energy
you guys hold up on this [ __ ]
e mustang we were just walking down the
street was like oh i don't just mean
you i just kept going uh
you some current events this episode is
brought to you by blue chew
guys it's been a rough year for
everybody including your boy
if you're like me you're feeling your
age more than ever especially in the
bedroom
it's really sad in there so it's time to
snap out of it spring is here it's time
to spring
into bluetooth bluetooth is a unique
online service that delivers the same
active ingredients as viagra cialis but
in chewable form
at a fraction of the cost bluetooth
tablets help men achieve harder stronger
erections to combat all forms of ed
erectile dysfunction bluetooth is the
online prescription service
so no visits with doctor office no
awkward conversations
no wait in line at the pharmacy ships
right to your door discreet little
package
process is super simple sign up at
bluetooth.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers
once you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days it's all done
online so if this sounds like something
you can use in the bedroom your girls
can be stoked
visit bluechew.com for more details and
important safety information
and i got a deal for you guys try
bluetooth free when you use the promo
code fighter at checkout just pay five
dollar shipping
that's bluechew.com promo code fighter
to receive your first month
free and i thank them for being part of
the podcast man i like beer
but i'm thick dude so i gotta be careful
i can't be drinking that full beard
i'm not talking about the light stuff i
need no sugar all right i need around 92
calories then coors pure came along it's
an organic beer that's right
zero sugar and only 92 calories
it's perfectly crisp refreshing bear to
reach for while you're living a balanced
lifestyle we're talking about a healthy
lifestyle man
nothing wrong with a cold one a cold run
from
coors pure all right it's all organic
zero sugar so you can enjoy it without
feeling guilty
you're not gonna feel all bloated all
right of course pure
organic but they're chill about it not
pushing your face all right
new course beer is refreshingly simple
bear with organic barley
organic hops and water and at 92
calories and zero sugar is the perfect
bear to celebrate
the winds of life every day you guys got
this man all right so if you want to try
it out you want to try that perfect
beard to celebrate the winds of your
life and
also that healthy life man you can have
beer and also not feel guilty so when
you want to enjoy a beer without all the
guilt reach for coors pure it's organic
but they're chill about it go to
coorspure.com to see where you can find
coors pure
celebrate responsibility coors brewing
company albany georgia
this episode of finding the kids is
brought to you by the one
the only the baddest the best
supplements on the planet we call earth
we talk about
on it on it supplements whether you're
on a diet like your boy
never been stronger thanks to on it
thanks a lot of hard work
that's right you need supplements to get
to where you're going
to get them gains dog if you thick and
trying to get in shape
let ana help you out little new mood
total gut health we got
joint oil we got freaking krill oil we
got creatine man
blow up with that creatine we got
protein powders we got it all
we got freaking warrior bars we got
nutrition
we got fitness for you ass we got uh
coffee they have everything you need
streaming fitness do it from your home
if you don't want to go to the gym we
got kettlebells on it in 30
kettlebell athletes morning mobility
that's 30 minutes of your day
how you stream that [ __ ] on it six
barbell on at six body weight we got it
all man go to on it.com
fighter 10 off everything i just told
you about okay
so brendan you sent this to us there was
a
whole catfishing thing with a missing
girl oh you want to get into it
you got it's so [ __ ] good it's so
good
so check this out so i'll read
barstool's caption says a well-known uh
when a well-known lakers podcast host
went missing her co-host tweeted asking
for help
and nba twitter stepped up and found out
she's been a catfish the whole time
for years what they think is this this
dude
has been portraying himself as the host
and the co-host
so he'll like talk change his voice he's
the woman
and even the woman to laugh at like his
bad jokes and goes back and forth and
they
so she went miss for whatever reason i
don't know why he did this
so hey lakers family look vivian flores
is missing
may or may not be wearing a wig because
she's going
through leukemia and all this [ __ ] what
it's
nuts dude keep scrolling down that's
what she looks like
that's what she looks like so fans got
involved and found out that this lady's
actually
i guess she can do something with a app
where you can change the face and take
the face put on something they found out
this this girl's been
honey-dicking everybody so there it is
so scroll up so it says
this then breaking down barstool did a
great job sunday night uh tassant sends
out some wearing tweets flores was
missing
uh so tassant is the co-host yeah
florence was missing and her family's
asking to help find her so he posted
that right love you all stay safe let us
know if you find her so keep going
and then uh even uh [ __ ] ice cubes
goes no way are you serious everyone
please retweet this anyone they are
she's so such a dope person let's find
her so it's like oh damn it's real keep
going and then la lakers
absolutely vivian is part of the family
how nuts i read this whole thing it's
insane and it's [ __ ] nice
and she's not even so then even uh kevin
garnett got involved i didn't listen to
this kevin durant
it's uh it's fairly long about to play a
clip of it so i guess this guy big kings
was fooled by the same person vivian
flores before so kevin durant's asking
how
how are you falling for this whatever so
he actually being catfish
and this thing called twitter space i
don't know what it is it's like because
i guess too they found out that they
sort of they found out that this catfish
guy or girl whoever's doing it did this
back in the day for the
readers a bunch of different things same
picture everything for the raiders
oh so i played this real quick this is
insane oh yeah it's not and k.d
it was uh he was locked in y'all slow
down for a second
all right so so you're saying who the
hell is king
the [ __ ] right there big king
so kevin garnett and then keep going
that's all that chatter [ __ ]
and then oh yeah so it says oh yeah
these catfish relevations were coming
out vivian was found huge cyber so that
that co-host goes oh [ __ ]
uh vivian has been found alive and safe
thank you for all the help and
everyone's like nah dawg
so then they started investigating it
throughout all this nba twitter
detectives poured over the accounts
entire history of posting
looking for areas of sloppy catfishing
and then it popped up look at this very
bad photoshop look at her pictures
look at that picture oh who fell for
this [ __ ]
and then keep going like lakers time i'm
crying there's no way she got away with
this look at her picture
no one no one thought it was keep going
down dog look at this
no this is the best this is the best one
so keep going
look at you're like you see the picture
right a little suspect okay keep going
and then and then some guy goes how did
nobody figure out that she put her first
name on the back jersey
keep going photo shopping looking uh
yourself hooping overseas should be
punishable that's what he said overseas
like what does that mean
they see this deal they did a result and
look there's the real lady
what that [ __ ]
yo she photoshopped her face yeah i
wanted to keep going
interesting keep going this is the best
catfishing thing since that uh
mateo on the uh notre dame oh man and
then look do you all realize how
advanced we face technology is these
days look up the name sharon alexey
so they take that who's a baddie takes
that model's face
this model look that's the real model so
they stole her face
and put it on that girl [ __ ] and they
show a clip here
and then look you still haven't got a
goddamn explanation this is that co-host
he's trying to
because they think he's behind it all
right he was telling me we got a goddamn
explanation thought i'd trust someone
and learn my lesson
try to help a friend i thought it was in
pearl i was duped like y'all
and feel bad i was upon such garbage
logging off for a while stay
safe out there you never know so that he
thought he'd be good
he thought it'd be good not good
he's not good he was i didn't address
this earlier in the day because i wanted
to confirm viv
with vivian what happened i didn't
receive that i was also protecting my
mental health because rumors spread like
wildfire
uh thank you to everyone who reached out
keep going down
and then and then her profile pops up
the catfish is talking about yeah
y'all be on here hearing the side of the
story of one guy and then automatically
assume he's right about everything
i have people on here can verify who i
am i don't need to prove anything to
anyone as far as me going missing
yes it happened i passed out from my
treatment remember [ __ ] she had cancer
leukemia
so keep going no dude this is insane oh
it's so weird keep going chin past this
yeah are you gone yep
hold on so i'm gonna i'm gonna let you
all have you all fun tonight get all the
jokes off you want on me when [ __ ] drops
let's see who has the last laugh
enjoy the game peace sign and apparently
that's bam at a bio they said that she
posted
like an actual video to prove it was her
but it got deleted right away
so i didn't get to see the video i was
looking around for it yeah it's nuts
and then there's a big cat she really
not
um most 99.99 is not a real girl keeps
going down
and then it says you know scroll up chin
it goes it goes vivian uh
just kind of goes away for a bit as
overwhelming evidence pours in it's a
catfish
and the theories abound and the scroll
down because
this guy put out curiosity i pitched
down vivian's voice from the lakers
podcast because
they host a laker all lakers podcast you
know uh lakers probably see what it
sounds like without any potential
effects that could be used to make it
sound higher
people start looking into it so it's
pitch down so they drop it lower right
drop detuning they not wins that we won
uh against
teams like the contenders that obviously
they think it's an australian new
zealand guy 100
i'm not mistaken both teams 500 i think
yeah uh yeah so that was it so that's
not much real
yeah so then this guy sounds like
australian academy not that this
evidence or anything i'm just trying to
figure out if it's audio effects
and then he goes into it he was for the
record i uh i'm a former audio engineer
i'd say the exercise has made me think
it's possible that the pitch shifting
was used but not guaranteed
pretty sure that pod is two different
people though unless it's really get
voices
keep scrolling down look me starting my
new laker spot
[Laughter]
so that's the podcast right there it's a
big pocket yeah look now but look reader
when i suggest someone record themselves
in a modular female voice to laugh at
their own joke but poorly clipped audio
and i tell you i'm tweeting this with
tears streaming down my face let me hear
it
now i've truly lived yeah listen this
like uh imagis is the same guy
fresh prince of air carlton chucking it
from half court
and uh but he took a bunch of
they took they were taking a bunch of
shots like listen
run your off how weird that was yo a
little laughing between so he can mix
that ladder
as an audio engineer that's going to be
tough to do to do that so much work yeah
if it is it's possible it's suddenly
just another person it might be just
another person that's not really that
girl
it's just another person either it could
be a guy or a girl or some guy who's a
beast doing both characters
recording ain't going bro he should be
you should probably audition for sound
i was just about to say i got xbox
connect you can highlight look hey do
you recognize this girl by chance
because it's the real girl look at this
oh that's the fake girl yep how long you
be in new york city for
okay i'll be waiting that's in 2009 yeah
it's the same girl using the same
profile
it's a big catfish account i went along
with 11 years ago to see how far would
go and expose them
the original impersonated model roberta
little under the name joanna peters
i contacted her agency a few times but
heard nothing back
and their podcast is just audio yes i
mean it has to be just audio that's just
audio
but but all that work for audio podcast
is not you said killing like that i
don't
say they said it had three episodes so i
guess some people subscribe to it
this is like a well-known i don't know
about the whole well-known thing i think
they're joking it's bar stool yeah i
think they're joking keep scrolling down
new development video used to go by the
name of kelly little butterfly 88 and
was knee-deep in the i'd say ball's deep
in the raiders twitter this [ __ ] is
insane
oh this was your time it was the same
girl yeah but she was doing it for the
[ __ ]
raiders raiders damn
so hold on no how nuts is that yeah as
of now there's still plenty of questions
like i guess there's really only one
who's going to co-host the lakers
podcast with that guy josh
and will he or she or won't he or she be
an
actual person how nuts is that it's
creepy it gives me the chills
so much work exhausting like [ __ ]
chill
what he should just come out like yo
i've been doing both cause i can't find
another co-host
it's been so much work i'd love a real
podcast host
but well why create a story that no one
asked for
leukemia the then he i think he didn't
know was going to be you wanted
attention he's like oh she's missing
get attention strictly attention that's
when people like huh even though they
looked into it
damn yeah that's just it a lot what's up
on your deepest darkest suit
everything i'm glad i don't have no
twitter that sounded like a dude though
when they deep
way deep uh pitched the audio that was
like an australian is it crazy well
they d pitched it to make it sound like
a dude if they put pushed it back up to
the normal thing
you would hear the voice but i'd rather
hear the actual normal voice oh it is no
sound of the normal voice
no this is this is called twitter's [ __ ]
right yeah
twitter oh gosh
at the end of the day my mind is just
[ __ ]
yeah that's how i feel right now but
that's how catfishing is because that's
why
because it's like a lot of people like
this you're like what the [ __ ]
but again i watch that show on mtv
catfish and it's just so much
work but people are really i can see
somebody sending money
people they've never met you see the one
where
he goes and meets the girl and it's not
her she's like a big nose it's a big
girl bigger girl
and then she goes uh i got something
else to tell you and then she pulls out
her eye
you didn't see that no yeah now and it's
like hey you didn't need to tell him
that
i don't even know that no i could gladly
you ever seen the one where it's it's
like uh the girl thinks she's talking to
a guy and they're like in love and she's
talking about moving away with them
and then they look more into it and it's
like her sister no
no yeah that's that's scary some of
those catfishes are [ __ ] insane it
was
like how much they could be like how
much money like i said probably
three thousand dollars over the last two
years and like you've never faced i'm
like
no they have bad service so they can't
do it even like you've never seen him in
person like no
that's what they do we supposed to be at
a park one time but he said he couldn't
make it
yeah it's just like we figure it out we
webcam figure it out
but some people are just i mean they
fall in love so i know
it was one episode where she people just
want to be loved a guy got catfished
and she like she didn't look like
anything like the picture but she was
bad
and he was so mad like you lied to me
and all that like she's hotties but she
was bad but we'll also figure it out
he was like i can't believe i i'm
because you know nev got started because
he got catfished yes yes who is
i bet there's a lot more people out here
and started the show you know there has
yeah
yeah but you need to watch that is that
show still going on yeah it is so yeah
you have a new co-host do you remember
the same co-host the girl really thought
she was talking to bawwa
no oh you okay you know what i'm talking
about i've seen that one
you've never seen the one where uh they
like someone thought they were talking
like brad pitt
and neve was like i just i don't know
how much we gotta look into this but
uh i don't think it's brad pitt how can
they be
no like no i talk to him all the time
it's so crazy some people will use very
popular like recognizable people and
they still get catfished
like there's this model on instagram she
goes by golden barbie her name's jasmine
oh she's a beautiful woman
uh this catfish used her photos as like
this girl and this guy's like no
it's her it's her neve actually got the
actual model
on facetime to talk to him she's like no
like i actually don't
i'm not on social media sites that
you're on right now like that is the
model
um
golden barbie yeah but she's like very
recognizable
uh-huh she's very popular oh okay she's
bad oh that's
super bad but yeah they facetimed her
and she's like no that's not me you're
getting catfished oh can it be you damn
the sign right now she got chin damn
that's funny as [ __ ] where my space is
this right here oh so we were talking
about this last episode about colton
underwood potentially facing backlash
from the
lgbt community for monetizing off of his
coming out story why are they mad at him
like this though and now there's a
petition
there's a position i'm telling you to
cancel a show
any of those [ __ ] would take
that show all of them anybody but what's
he supposed to if they're like oh you're
gonna come out
yeah like oh well we'll pay you seven
million to do it on yeah what do you
want to do
yeah all right [ __ ] it i was gonna do it
anyways yeah my dad watching good
morning mega this is great
[Laughter]
my dad would definitely see this i mean
i bet you netflix won't cancel it no why
would that mean it's good
it's only twenty five thousand ain't
terrible what 25 000 people
like wrote to him netflix like [ __ ] oh
that's oh that's easy
yeah uh yeah just don't watch it if you
don't want to support it don't watch it
but isn't it advocate for
for the lgbtg
people are looking for any reason i
guess to you to hate
they're just looking for a reason to
hate hate whatever happens they want to
hate something
but but again they're mad he's going to
show and he's gay
i think people are uh upset that he's
monetizing off of this
what's he supposed to do who wouldn't do
that thank you very true
no man let that man do his thing bruh
25 000 like how bored are you because
this guy getting bread yeah why you
hating like yeah
it's probably how much you and when you
really think about how much does it
affect their
like what they're doing at all how much
does it affect
at all and you know how many suggestions
netflix gives you you don't have to
watch it that's what i'm saying if you
don't
like it don't support it but it's
important but people don't like but to
try to take it
like go after netflix and be like nah
take this [ __ ] off but i guess i guess
it's still supporting his backstory it's
like where people like he was on
bachelor
and then he came i didn't get it and
then he had he had a charge against them
yeah so against the girl he was like
stalking her yeah he
had a restraining order you know
i think there's some question with his
sexuality people like think maybe it's a
marketing thing but yeah
dude's gay like you watch one episode i
called it from the jump
so wait there's a there's a story about
him stalking the girl that he was yes
so he was with the woman uh about a year
ago they broke up and shortly after
breaking up she filed a restraining
order against him saying that he's
stalking her well hold on i wonder why
hold on it might be on the side why is
he stolen she removed it though right uh
i'm not sure how yeah she
she took it yeah i think why are you on
his side for talking
well yeah no on his own honestly getting
up today you're saying that the people
trying to cancel them yeah the people
that's wrong
well it says casey ran up cassie
randolph filed her stranger against
colton underwood in september ran off
claiming would put a tracking device on
her car and send her numerous texts must
even pretend to be a nonstop oh
hell no that's crazy but she
but she dropped the restraining order
yeah also we don't know the relationship
dog mm-hmm like now that he's out that's
just one side do you believe that or no
yeah i mean i mean he was obviously
doing something to get restrainer but
also you're talking about a guy who's
in the closet gay he's on this
bachelorette show or where the [ __ ] he
was on
and he's like trying to figure life out
probably not doing great mentally wise
so probably freaked the [ __ ] out dude
he's trying to be with dave and he's
with cassie
yeah you know so he's probably not doing
well
and now he's finally gay now they want
to cancel him over this he's like god
damn dude how many years ago was that uh
that was recent a year maybe like a year
ago oh but she dropped the charge what
what you guys mad at
yes she got over it yeah she dropped
yeah we don't know what happened
yeah what am i to say about it
yeah it was filed in september september
all right all right yeah i just don't
get i don't like what people just like
you know i mean let that man do his
thing though
yeah um
oh bro dude she was triggered because
they had
sugar-free froyo i don't get your fat
ass out of the frozen yogurt
store if you're triggered by [ __ ]
sugar-free yogurt
if you can't go in the store without
being triggered
what's wrong with you don't go there
so i find finding it extremely hard to
order froyo from the
big chill official when you have to walk
past tons of sugar-free cookies
and other diet foods before you get to
the counter do better please
hashtag diet culture vultures and this
is a big chills
and then big chill said uh we are not
diet vultures we cater
we cater to all our customers needs for
the past 36 years we are sorry you found
this offensive
but also it's up to you to figure it out
and they wrote this too they carry that
they care about those for diabetics
disease vegans of course have many other
indulgent items as well
and then she doubled down she was you
can carry things right so she doubled
down yeah yeah
she goes you can carry things for other
people also caring for another
percentage of your customers who
struggle daily
just even stepped on your door hey don't
step
foot in the frozen yogurt store if
you're overweight
you don't have to keep your fat ass out
of the store
i do it that's what we do yeah you don't
see me up in there being triggered
wait but it's also sugar-free i don't
that's why it doesn't make sense to me i
don't get why she's upset
right now hold on she goes you can find
a way to provide an inviting environment
for all people with different needs
including eating disorders
one of the deadliest mental illnesses
only second to opiate
overdoses which he has both um don't
make excuses just do better
the big chill just didn't they just
didn't respond to that because there's
nothing to say like it
i mean what do you say today if i was
being chill i'd be
if you don't have the discipline to come
in and not be mentally affected by your
[ __ ] frozen yogurt
are you out of your mind yeah i don't go
to bars i don't drink no
bars i don't want i don't want that i
love pizza you don't see me in pizza hut
because i can't be around pizza
you imagine me hey pizza i find it
extremely offensive
that you guys offer pepperoni pizza when
you know i'm overweight
that's basically what she said what the
hell it's
nuts man she got lit up by the body
though yeah oh everybody lit her up
that's why she even people overweight
were like what i just can't believe
she's serious
what does she like when she's she's
bored she's mentally ill that's what's
going on
yeah and i wouldn't even i wouldn't even
give it no energy is she on like a
weight loss journey
her entire life is a weight loss yeah i
mean it's up and down
she's gained more and i'm a demi lovato
i love her
amazing i'm very outspoken about things
i believe in i understand sometimes
messages can lose meaning we'll get when
i get emotional i'm human
so don't tweet do better please keep
going
that was it i think but that's all that
[ __ ] is like it's just a bunch of
emotional people
on twitter and all that [ __ ] like that's
that's all it is now froyo
is that doesn't add weight to you do it
does it
yeah it does does it's [ __ ] ice cream
no do you say it's yogurt it's ice cream
paint it whatever [ __ ] picture you
want there's tons of sugar in it
people put reese's on top and sprinkles
that's fantastic
gosh and you'll be putting that [ __ ] on
there too dog i put that those acai
the [ __ ] uh pomegranate little
coconut yeah
get the vanilla what's your froyo order
i'm not a big froyo guy
if you had to go do you have like
something you would go to i go to
pinkberry when i was in flight camp
every friday i would get the uh
my girl like the tart with the uh
pomegranates and coconut
we used to do that all the time in
marina del rey so good and i was never
triggered
[Laughter]
my day i'm going to look at this froyo
stuff all right you might like it
i might it's not i mean i just rather
have regular ice cream yeah
regular ice cream i mean nothing beats
[ __ ] salt and straw that's all i'm
saying
yeah salt strawberry we had an argument
and and we're not out of discussion
baskin robbins 31 flavors and i said
dairy queen
yeah exactly but you've never had an
upside down so you can't be in the
conversation
how are you gonna handle something their
hat i didn't hate it you're demi lovato
you said you did what you told me okay
you're triggered by a blizzard
all right that hard shell cone they dip
it in that [ __ ] chocolate come on
daddy come on
come on good good [ __ ] yeah
too thick but man that dairy queen like
you can have it once a year if you're
like
too thick and then they fold it and [ __ ]
i don't like all that
[ __ ] i like salt
you ever been to south stronghold you
just got delayed so good i lived here
before i just never
oh man there's one up on largemont
there's one off main street studio city
where are you in again you're in the
valley huh yeah north hollywood
studio cities what else you got jen go
do that
all right okay
so a bunch of uh fans have tagged all of
us
in this i haven't seen this because
there is a carnival fight that breaks
out in opa-locka
and there is there are two clips there's
one clip that went viral and another
clip that showed what happened before
the fight broke out so this there's no
kids in it right
there so this first clip is what went
viral this is before
the incident that incited this fight
so this is just a fight watch the baby
though
she's not horn though i talk to people
wait why is she mad because look i'll
show you the video later there's a look
at the baby
oh no she's good though the baby good
why is that guy fighting these two moms
and he's getting [ __ ] up [ __ ] up the
whole hood oh everyone jumped
in on it oh but but that's what he gets
why would you hit a woman no just wait
until you see what he did before that
yeah
he was doing some crazy things this is
after he did something that was he he
logged the machine and he hit these
people i think he was who added that
right here look no that's you stop it
so yeah somebody added audio into it
this is what happened before
which is why everyone was angry hope
that baby's okay yeah now she's good
this is what he did what do you do look
he pushed that kid out
and just started the ride oh oh i would
[ __ ] him
up and he starts yelling at the people
who are in the
cart and again where people are yelling
at him including his coach
his co-workers oh [ __ ] that's his
co-worker right there oh he has a
problem yeah
so this is what happened before the
fight the moment he let another family
off is when the fight started oh yeah
i'd fight him 100 percent that's why
everyone was i'm glad he got his ass
yeah yeah but this is opa-locka
i don't know if you guys want to go nice
yeah yeah
yeah she's she's like what the [ __ ] you
doing my kid almost got [ __ ] up man
you just started oh we fighting
because you don't want to let the people
out mm-hmm she got a baby
she said you know what the hell is
and all she's doing is talking he got
physical with it and then the baby fell
she good though i hope he got jumped i
hope yeah
the whole group is [ __ ] up literally
everyone in mind is that a mighty wings
jersey
[ __ ] yeah charlie but then he's stuck
he's some somehow he gets off and he
press the button again yeah
i wonder what a piece of [ __ ] dude
look [ __ ] start the machine boom oh
jesus god damn
and they're going fast yeah oh that guy
needs to be fired man
i hope they went back and jumped his ass
yeah he was fired but
the uh company who runs the carnival is
not releasing his name
not releasing well they'll find out the
the internet will find him he's [ __ ]
yeah
that's right yeah this is what happened
shortly before
gosh how can you get that upset to harm
people when the ferris wheel
oh no initially when the live working
the ferris wheel
[Laughter]
[Applause]
why
hey no we fighting though yeah yeah
yeah initially that first video that i
showed you of the fight actually went
viral a lot of people were
saying well we don't know what uh the
woman did before she shouldn't have had
gone in his face and then somebody
released the full video
they were like oh no point
yeah right oh she didn't even she didn't
even hit him she was yeah
and she had every right so you push
she's pulling her kid yeah yeah
absolutely
we fighting fighting opel stand up
stand up we're here at 305 man
um this one okay so
bts your favorite korean boy band
they're gonna get their straight up
favorite band
point blank period um they're getting
their own
mcdonald's meal and their mcdonald's
meal is pretty simple i believe it's
medium because
they come with the corn sauce they have
their two own sauces
a uh sweet chili and a cajun
so it's ten piece nuggets medium
fructose makes no sense because of
korean band but whatever
uh i think it's supposed to mimic like
gochujang which is a korean chili paste
call it nothing
very true yeah but yeah bts is gonna
have their own meal and i think it's
coming out within the next month my
son's gonna be crazy
tiger's been lit as [ __ ] so is malik
no he don't like bts no he likes those
little kid meals
yeah that's right no bro the nuggets six
piece
six pieces south sweet chili's gonna be
fantastic i'm in it comes
it comes in on may 27th may yes okay i
wonder if they released uh like a
special toy with it
i don't know do these meals usually have
toys
like they did it for uh the raya toy and
the trolls toys but did they have it for
the travis scott or the uh but he only
had a sandwich he only i mean he had a
burger because it's the same thing where
it's like uh
they're not necessarily happy
just to see if this it jay is
mcflurry it was like uh i forget it was
like
peanut butter caramel white yeah [ __ ]
it's gone oh some people been doing
mcdonald's collabs for a minute just
like the past year
i think it started dressing last like
six seven months because i was like luna
never heard of it
and yeah that's alvin mcflurry no well
my son loves mcdonald's
which mcdonald's you go to i don't want
calabasas
oh that that sure that is true
cream machine working yeah right every
time we go that one on chris shaw
everybody's quiet if i see the mcflurry
is that his meal that comes with the
mcflurry or it's just uh
looks like it was like his special who
is that yeah
probably the most famous latin artist in
the world sorry
you don't know james alvin no i bet
you'd know some of his songs he's all
over the radio
he had his own jordans he's so big doug
he was on jordan once
he was on that song with cardi b uh i
like it yeah
he's on what uh i like it with cardi b
yeah he was rapping spanish
oh yeah he only does spanish he's
[ __ ] fired
oh i can't wait so bts gonna have a meal
i'm like with the sweet chili i mean
you can't be oh yeah jim you're right
chill all right
i watch my son eat it though
like damn i don't know what i'm gonna do
i'm gonna watch tiger yeah
[Laughter]
the taste of it yeah oh the biggest news
of the week month whatever you want to
call it
derek sheldon found guilty on all
charges i was loading up my guns and
chickens if he would have got off it
would have been
hell on earth doggy now
now the only other reason they would
write is if you know they're good i
think they're going to
give them his sentencing next week i'd
say a couple of they say a couple
it's a couple weeks so when they do to
the sense then
there could be some backlash with that
because i think
so they're getting them on that uh
second that first star the second degree
i think the maximum times 40 years he
won't get 40.
it's up to the judge's discretion and
he's a cop
so i bet you he serves around 12 years
that's what i think and people can be
pissed
i mean there's a great first step though
thank god this happened you want some
you want to hear crazy
i told chin to get the camera equipment
out of the studio yeah well
because they protest down they blew it
down here did you hear what
uh they said though that i mean i really
hope
just because i don't want to deal with
this for another eight months uh i
really hope
that yeah not the retrial there was
someone who said that
uh i don't know who it was was telling
people that they should riot
more and harder so we uh they forced the
jury to convict
uh derek cops the maxine waters right
the lady the yeah i think i don't
remember the idea but
but she's such an idiot what by her
saying that saying we should uh
riot harder do you give them another
reason for a retrial that she's
completely [ __ ] up that's what the
judge
said the judge uh the judge is like we
it could be like a mystery island he
could get off yeah because the jury
like the jury is so worried about
violence that they found him guilty so
there's gonna be a retrial 100 which i
i really hope there's not because the
retards can be found guilty we'll be
fine
yeah if he would have got off we'd been
[ __ ] oh my god yeah
yeah all right so
right when this the the conviction
whatever came in
the raiders posted this and it was like
up and down and when people thought it
was terrible some people thought it was
it was fine i can breathe yeah so they
posted i can breathe on their twitter
yeah raiders [ __ ] up man that was a
call by the owner
yeah i know but then uh the brother
george george floyd's brother said
i guess during the trial like he says i
can finally breathe now and that's where
they took it from and
the brother is not mad at this at all
that's cool yeah so they meant well
obviously it's just really toned down
you're saying that well because everyone
was on pins and needles
because you know we
you know you know they're trying to do
something nice here right there
but then it's just toned down this
shouldn't be a news
article the uh what nancy pelosi uh said
yeah should have been what she said she
hate that she basically
thank you
say it twice because i mean what he said
look she said basically saying she's
glorifying
like he's basically like yo he took one
for the team his death his murder
was basically like yeah well she's just
old and poor choice of words
but thank you thank you georgetown for
giving your life
sacrificing for your sacrifice
i mean she's just stupid i'm gonna get
her out of there hopefully she gets
hopefully they're right at her
in front of her house behind all these
black people
behind her his one woman face at the end
when she heard that sh
oh really she like hold on she was oh
she said it what the hell is this she
said sacrifice in your life
let me play this oh can we play podcast
people be [ __ ] up
we saw it happen and thank god
the jury validated what we saw
what we saw so again thank you george
floyd
for sacrificing your life for justice
for being there to call out to your mom
she was like but they're nodding
no one's speaking no one's speaking up
would you to stop them [ __ ] yeah if i'm
george floyd if i'm a black person
behind them like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about doug
your name will always like are you out
of your goddamn mind with
justice i think they probably put it to
the side like hey what's this like you
know you [ __ ] up
you know you're about to get recalled
that's what you're doing you know you're
about to get fired right
you know you've been riding you've been
riding with us this entire time you just
[ __ ] it all up right
you uber bet again we'll be in austin
tomorrow what is today stay wednesday
today
tomorrow so thursday april 22nd that's
tomorrow thursday
two shows thursday we're just at a late
show so let's get moving on tickets for
late show
uh early show thursday late show
thursday
two shows friday two shows saturday all
tickets are damn near sold out go to
fatkz.com for tickets austin we will see
you
tomorrow friday saturday then lexton
kentucky
them [ __ ] are flying off the shelves
may 6th through the 8th let's
lexington kentucky doggy then houston
texas may 23-22nd
the crew will be there f-a-t-k-z for
tickets
chappelle will be in philly philly north
carolina
philly may 6th through the 8th
at the helium comedy club yo i want to
try a badass philly cheesesteak stop
bullshitting and i want to know where
your [ __ ] gyms are at cause i got to
stay
on that 3 15. and then may 13th through
the 15th i'll be at good night's
comedy club in raleigh north carolina
tickets at chapellelacey.com
let's [ __ ] see you this week austin
love you guys hope you enjoyed the
discussion we're out